hey guys we're here with the official
Captain Cold character breakdown from
nether realm now this did come from a
developer livestream so if you see
something weird remember that it's a
work in progress and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for all the latest injustice
to character reveals and breakdowns
so here's captain Colton his default
yeah look um good walk nice jump got
something some air moves here nice
you've implemented his gun a lot in a
lot of moves yeah we were I really
wanted to use or we really wanted to use
the like that gun as much as possible
not just basic attack they want to use
it in its I saw I'm afraid as much as
you prefer because it just really mostly
it's the main weapon right it's an
iconic thing yeah I mean he's not like a
lot other character private ton of like
training in the martial arts are what
were superpowers right he's like I got
this manage his main go to right woods
so we can go through some of his uh you
want to do some combos do some general
strings sure we have like we got here
over night medium medium a that I use
them use the gun a lot in the x-ray okay
oh my god we do it's a knockdown Farsi
this is a fuel that will get to it soon
right but the way his gameplay plays
I'll move like that really hopeful that
it opens up with stuff you will talk
about right so since I move like that's
very important for how he plays we got
things like that good mix up yeah I
think there we go
I love that okay right there where you
incorporate the gun within is actually
there we go like that yeah so let's talk
about his fight style really like have
what it was his goal like the goat is
good as like when you're playing is
Captain Cold
what do you try to do the apartment I
mean you're really trying to get close
to everybody beat him down until you get
a point where you want to push them away
so you can do some of his other stuff
which right right so yeah that's kind of
like the main thing is he's a rebels
push you away for the most part so it
can set him up you want you gotta set up
for what he's put his abilities are
because he has sort of he has traps
taken like yes now some things like that
for single things - what you're used to
people really I think appreciate him I'd
like to try something completely
different you know and he is very
different so let's go ahead and get into
some of the special moves
let's just go friend forever oh yeah oh
you do the fries one of my favorite the
icicles that come off the back or one of
my favorite things shoutouts I get to
kill [ __ ] also I think and not
promising anything but I believe Gilmour
will be on the stream next week Oh
excellent sorry he does all the effects
yes it does a great job
amazing him and the effects team do
amazing US Marshal yeah and the rest of
the team as well
yeah simply get about everybody else
everybody else so let's so that sort of
his basic fight flow works for the most
part he wants to do when he's in close
his combos are gonna end pushing you
away to set him up for everything else
so let's go through the ice blast ice
blast we got cold blast right here yeah
I noticed the effect of it actually
hitting him it was really cold
see that better and definitely I thought
actually freeze anything it's just a
visual effect the frost so now this is
definitely a good zoning tool absolutely
when you're playing in this distance for
you will happen a lot this is ideal this
is where you want to be for the most so
there's that you've got the death sickle
what a great name has which does what it
says of roughing and it also could be
different distances so I can do all
three different distances so don't ruin
it no it's next all right so there is a
mutant bird
there's made of burn but we'll get back
to that one because that is very very
strategic to his tired very morose game
plan this is called the wall the wall so
you can throw a wall real quickly and it
will as you say led protecta rocks
become oh you can also get meter burn is
it know what guys are just one alien
inputs what is it it's right here on the
piece of paper it down back to it also
does damage yeah okay there we go so
yeah so meter burn though your this yep
yep another one alright I didn't run but
again there we go one two three oh geez
I messed it all right one two three
look at that or two I'm not gonna as
well it'll block all additional
professor it's soaked up everything am
knocking down and I got them down which
is very very useful it's something very
different than what we've done
previously like throw the shield order
heist and this is where his personality
kind of comes in where he's likely go
yeah you don't like the wall just you
know it's kind of personality blends it
likely try to get it as try to get easy
I know awesome so let's move on to where
we have the big three big free time I
three yeah this is kind of a like a
long-range almost sweet so it's a low
attack from kind of long-range should
you do little stagger stagger state the
good thing about this interesting is
that the meter burn version is a very
different functionality so the meter
burn is actually just a kind of like a
suck on ice freeze like like a hazard oh
my god has almost so like in just like
we were talking about like oh you're
trying to get in now I've done wall at
the wall now you would try to get in we
can I can bring on the ground and he
walk into I could do it so he is
definitely trying to just keep you keep
his spacing where he wants and within
combo so it works out really yeah you
can also like I can actually I can
actually show let's see if you can't add
I don't think I think I hope so there
you go so you're getting the really good
compliment oh oh don't you owe nobody
that's too much there you go a little
combo
alright let's um Captain Cold that's a
really cool movie yes frost filled down
for three I really like this boat this
is another thing that kind of seems them
kind of keeps them there and it's kind
of like slowly taking damage on them and
when you're inside of the bubble right
you stay in there long enough it's
you're losing yeah you live a good about
a health and and if you do a meter burn
version if you're gonna long enough
it'll actually freeze to play so you can
do either burn stay in it move here
comes Tyler's combo again but BAM hey
tumble of the water I am one go it's not
a common idiom so yeah that's that's
also that now the moment you've been
waiting for move this is this yes this
is I think okay tattoo like this yeah I
don't know how much they've seen in the
of this yet well they're not even see
would have used for so let's start by
talking about his uh his cyclotron gun
okay yes this character power which is
ability to overcharge his gun because uh
so in each level
he has three levels of it so each level
you allows him to have a new move that's
associated mm-hm so now if it's full
power
who decided me to do that preset I'd had
a series that later just so one part of
time yeah he says rent a level one bar
he allows him to put those on ice thorny
ice armor on himself frosted tips on
which I think yes is it's blue that's
called a brought two tips so there it is
so yeah which is really cool I love it
so now this does damage to the other
players plate a lot of times yes you're
getting them there they're taking damage
a yes or take so that that's just level
one yes level two level to go them a
little bit more up okay is right this is
like you know I kind of like a snow
globe type of thing you're slowly
getting colder inside of it and if you
also also slowed down a little bit as
well so it's longer you're in it to
slower you go and you also start to
freeze so if you're in a too long you'll
freeze and you're also reacting slower
I do like it's kind of like snow
it was funny it was called well that's
what I was asking for what I was in fact
I wanted to look for I would imagine a
social yeah so now I joined the interns
that sounds there's miss Collins in the
snow glow at the alcohol always stud
load and then we go on to level three
now here's the thing getting a level
three though that could take yeah each
level it takes a little bit longer to
build up so like the first level is
really fast so you get that out a lot
more in a match but the third level is a
little bit longer to get there now let's
but with gameplay wise right like I mean
for the most part like we were saying
before keeping your distance and stuff
like that when you knock the opponent
fullscreen that'll give you a few
seconds to build up your gun and things
like that well there's another thing
there is another thing this down so
let's say you have nothing right you
have I have no you guys um so you throw
a wall around knock them down first
right right yeah I'm following this is
where you bring down the Peter Byrne
versatile me testicle so me to burn
testicle there's a wall in place which I
think you came to jump over but they
jump over you bet I'm just gonna do some
of that yeah so that gives me x the only
time to charge up which is kind of the
whole concept of it right so you drop
that you got some time to space it out
so it's going to be any funding truck
and just like the desta chol you can
drop those at different distances for
dentists and you can have multiple ones
out there as well you can also drop it
on their head and drop on their head so
you can show so that's a multi of more
than one do you think you can drop it
amazing do more than one bank of nice
BOSU ball three
alright so it's level three day delivery
is a overcharge where it fully blasts
all three bars and it over charges the
gun so that we will see right here it's
a full screen I stood last
freezes wherever the fire is which would
be you know if you do it in palos oh you
didn't have a good thing oh that's what
you pop them up you do that's how commas
worked right yeah
I've heard so if I ever do don't use any
bars Oh up you use a puppies bark oh you
can I was trying to challenge you oh I
got it down I got I got I got okay let's
see if this works
BAM oh he's already through the daughter
phones you only free throws yeah
gotcha cool that's awesome drop a couple
of drop drops on my ice cube drops you
do with the main request but I'm just
gonna break through that oh no oh oh
yeah that's awesome
yeah both ways give him a gun on the
screen at the same time which is
something very different than we've done
before so it's definitely new cool
little mechanic this people are gonna
really do really cool stuff like
definitely like we talked about as you
probably see now his game plan is very
different man we fun to play against and
play ass absolutely that's what makes
games I mean that does match before
mixed games I'm gonna put up a wall and
I'm gonna cook
yep yeah other times I wish I could do
that Derek in real life
Oh put that wall up you know um so let's
go through some of this other stuff yeah
talk very Oh were you oh that's great
guys I'm just going to move right a lot
on we're going to now show some new
version some practice options there we
go play gotcha and loadout
- all right excellent now to show kind
of a version we made of hims different
version again we don't have all the gear
yet here so there's another cool sort of
green and white version of him his
accessories is got a sniper rifle oh
yeah one thing I do like to mention
though if depending on what level meter
of your character power you are the LED
on your light also matches the height of
the
you've also told me that now that if
it's level 3 is there is boost yes T so
when you're level 3 the some moves get a
boost like slight boost and what any
level so level 1 is a little bit faster
level sees a little have this have some
speed yeah now it's got some speed so
sometimes it's not worth burning your
character power because you want to have
the abilities a lot of augments to your
other dogs right cool so this has that's
a base character what's not a Oh what
was that this is an air - it has an air
- cool um like the effects on the ground
so you Haley off for I had a really good
idea comes with another special move we
can use a conjunction
oh yeah I was mentioning this earlier
what what is it what about this move
right here awesome air platform oh my
goodness for from that air platform you
can do your normal special around ground
special moves so I can do you know you
can do your normal blast and then you
can do at least two platforms before
hitting the ground again right it's
really cool so and it's actually fun
from the platform you can also do you
know come straight down you can jump
back jump forward so I must use it like
a double jump as well let's your mastery
right here super fun to use it's very
fun
because when you especially when you
like with in conjunction with the air -
I mess it up oh oh that's pretty awesome
yeah that way excited really excited I
got to get Paul the credit for the idea
for that move though I didn't come down
that's really cool you don't like low to
the ground - that's too low the ground
so those are just two more of his
ability unlocks venerability honk we
down here with the gear this these are
gear so all right super cool I guess
Captain Cold looks sick someone says oh
I thought it was so yeah people are
people are really singing to enjoy the
yeah really excited I was really a
positive a lot of positive stuff so yeah
I'm really excited I'm cool we have
another one we can show - right which
will do I do the wrong thing every time
I do the wrong thing you'll get an
adventure I have faith in you I don't
all right then you know you don't learn
from your mistakes and then that's a
bigger problem yeah
all right here we go another look very
cool another another gun look nice we
give him we gave him good move out there
buddy
yeah we had weakened now at air blast
zone more so I'm gonna try to jump out
of your ice blocks can feel it it's so
hard to hide knees right isn't it oh I
wasn't really trying oh you were no I
was just being a jersey first the buckle
you liked it you can see all the ice
effects he has has lose that little bit
of mist riding on wherever it hits
awesome check it out what else we add oh
yeah shoulder of cool yeah shoulder cold
so we always talk about when you play
dese's to eat like creating a character
to play the way you want them to yes
like let's say you're not into the whole
track game I don't want to stay back I
don't want to kind of rush down well
definitely that gives him the ability
getting clothes yeah you can and there
you go
using using his gun after action yes yes
ma'am once again incorporating he has
gone into mostly everything he does it's
a really innovative way to know let's
throw super Oh super
[Music]
another snow globe another sanella slow
loads you can show jump around in the
snow globe
yeah um show the speed change it's
really cool is it down or forward so you
can go in there and hit him
you see how he starts to freeze while
he's in there
I miss na I do love what his guns been
used it has this trail but yeah a vapor
trail he spins around yeah it was great
though um thanks that's awesome that's
kept occult yeah excellent guys thank
you very much thank you ladies you know
this is Brian LeBaron his players on
bottom video game Brian yep
loogie Brian we're now going to bring
Steve Brown